- [Instructor] As we have
talked about in many videos,
the United States Supreme
Court has a very different role
than the executive or
the legislative branches.
The executive branch of
course runs the government.
The legislative branch, they make the laws
and set the budgets.
And then the Supreme Court can rule
that a law is unconstitutional,
or it can interpret
laws in a specific case.
And when the Supreme Court
justices make these decisions,
they try to follow the
principle of stare decisis,
which is Latin for "let
the decision stand."
It's this idea of taking
previous decisions as an example.
And if we're in a similar case now,
then they just use that decision
as an example for this one.
This is closely associated
with the idea of precedent.
Precedent in everyday language means
something that has happened before,
an action or a decision
that we can use a guide
or as an example.
And that's exactly what the
Supreme Court tries to do.
If the Supreme Court has
made a previous ruling
on a similar case, that would
be considered a precedent
for this case.
The Supreme Court has been
often described as umpires,
like umpires in a baseball game.
Even Chief Justice John
Roberts described it as such
during his confirmation hearings.
And it's this idea that
they should be these
objective arbiters of what the truth is,
of what is constitutional and what is not.
What does a law actually mean?
But we know in reality,
these are human beings.
And no matter how unbiased
and no matter how objective
they try to be, they
still bring to the table
their views and their experiences.
And so even though this seems
like a very clean process,
there's definitely a large
degree of subjectivity here.
And because the executive branch,
in particular the president,
can appoint Supreme Court justices,
there's definitely examples in history
of changes in politics
having long-term effects
on changes in the Supreme Court.
For example, a significant
case of overturning precedent
happens from 1896 to 1954.
In 1896, you have the
Plessy v. Ferguson case
that we covered in several other videos,
where the then Supreme Court
rules its laws that involve
segregation are okay.
But then you fast-forward almost 60 years,
and then the Supreme Court then,
in Brown v. Board of Education
in Topeka, ruled that no,
separate but equal is not constitutional,
that segregation is not okay.
And this was influenced by
this idea of, over time,
you had presidents who were able to
make judicial appointments
to the Supreme Court
as members of the Supreme
Court died or retired,
and went through a Senate
confirmation process,
and then these justices have life tenure.
They can stay on the Supreme
Court until they pass away
or until they decide to retire.
And so many historians would
say that this overturning
of precedent was due
to a change in politics
from the 1930s through the early 1950s.
When you have several terms of FDR
and then you have President Truman,
who appointed justices
to the Supreme Court
that would eventually rule on
Brown v. Board of Education,
and they would be more pro-civil rights.
And what's interesting about this is
even though presidents
try to appoints folks
who they believe would maybe
vote the way they would
or have similar views, many times,
it doesn't always work that way.
For example, President
Eisenhower, who was a Republican,
appointed Justice Earl Warren,
who was a Republican
governor of California,
but Warren ended up being famous
for taking more liberal stances than not,
including on Brown v. Board of Education.